On the outcome of the results yesterday,
it seems that it's very unlikely that labor can form government.
And on the basis that the Liberal Party have one more seat
and convention would dictate that
the governor would ask the Premier to form government,
whether it's in the parliament or with the support of the cross bench.
That is the likely outcome of this election result.
I respect that outcome. I respect the will of the people.
Uh, and I'm very grateful to the people of lines
who've given me their support.
I have already reached out to, uh, independence,
uh, potential independence and indeed, uh,
the Lambie Party as well. And, uh,
look forward to, uh,
those ongoing, uh, discussions, uh,
to ensure that I'm confident, uh,
that, uh,
the new people that are elected, uh,
to the Tasmanian parliament, uh,
will want that certain, the instability that Tasmanians,
of course, uh, clearly deserve.